[Music]
how do we find clothing companies that
use good quality fabrics and treat their
workers fairly
hmm this is the perfect time to talk
about green washing ryan yeah what is
green washing oh it's a company it makes
me think of uh like seventh generation
for example like
they they do a good job of doing
unscented things they try to use you
know chemicals that are good for the
environment but it's a it's a gimmick
it's not like an actual company that is
really worried about um
uh having a positive impact on the
environment they just they use the green
as a marketing play essentially so is
that what you mean by greenwashing yeah
so let's be clear no company worries
about the environment because companies
can't worry right right and so there may
be someone at the head of a company
like a b corporation which we talked
about on the minimal episode they're on
the public episode there
a b corporation does have some sort of
social responsibility yeah and they want
to have a social and environmental
positive effect right so greenwashing
here is the specific definition
greenwashing is the process of conveying
a false impression or providing
misleading information about how a
company's products are more
environmentally sound green washing is
considered an uns substantiated claim to
deceive customers into believing that a
company's products are more
environmentally friendly than what they
are i work contacts and there's a brand
that i've stopped buying but i i was
buying it because of the green washing
like it's
they do a great job of marketing you're
like oh i'm
somehow helping the environment by
buying this
brand of contact uh contact cleaner
contact solution and now i just like do
the off-brand stuff because it's pretty
much the same thing but yeah i mean we
it's very easy to fall for and so we can
talk about
well
how do we
how do we find companies right
because we're getting back to michelle's
question clothing companies in
particular yeah well here's what i do so
most of my t-shirts are bought from a
company purchased from a
a company called la apparel
and i know that a they're manufacturing
the united states which
incorporates certain regulations that
are more helpful for workers but also
they pay way above minimum wage they're
manufactured here in los angeles right
and so understanding this isn't green
washing it seems to me that the owner
does care about paying a living wage to
his workers and even if it is used
solely
as a marketing ploy look how great we
treat our employees okay great wonderful
yeah
and
quite often in their marketing emails
and stuff they often feature their
employees who are in so you see there's
a bit of transparency there you get to
see the the employees who are in the
factory sewing because
94
of garment manufacturers in the united
states still work in sweat shop-like
conditions that's crazy so just because
something is manufactured in the usa
doesn't mean that it's inherently good
or sustainable right right the most
sustainable item is the item that you
leave on the shelf and so i if i have to
take an item off the shelf and bring it
home with me then yes i often do
consider where else
is this money going it's going to the
workers yeah it's going for socially
conscious uh values that align with my
own values yeah
i love what you kind of said there about
you know the environmentally conscious
decision is to buy less clothing
it's not about finding a company we're
like oh i can buy all the clue thing i
want and they're doing the best to it's
no like you don't need all that clothing
i literally i use son of a tailor they
tailor the shirts there i know that
they're they're very conscious with
sourcing material i know that they pay
their workers well i forget what you
know what country they're based out of i
don't but it's uh it's like a country
that really um values it's it's it's
workforce and it goes out of its way to
give them a good work give them good
working conditions
um but but that's it it's like it's that
one brand i don't buy a million of them
i just buy what i need but it's not like
i use that company as an excuse to just
buy as many clothing items as i want
yeah and one might even argue that let's
say you bought from one of these fast
fashion places right like zara or
topshop or h m right
if you had bought five black shirts from
them
and then wore them until they wore out
yeah it's probably better than buying a
hundred shirts from the most sustainable
company right yeah and so keeping in
mind
the
quantity of consumption
impacts
the environment
just as much as the quality of the
things that we are buying yeah 100 now
in terms of looking for companies that
treat their employees fairly the most
popular website for that is a website
called glassdoor so i have an article
here from fairy godboss which i'll put a
link to this article in the show notes
it's called 11 sites where you can find
employee reviews so if you want to know
who's treating their employees fairly
you can go to glassdoor there's a few
other um websites you can go to as well
like indeed or vault or awesome career
bliss glassdoor is the most popular one
but it's employees review their
employers that's right wow now you have
to take that with a grain of salt as
well because quite often it's
disgruntled employees who feel compelled
to go on there yeah it makes me think of
uh i forget the website it was but where
students um review their professors yes
and uh yeah like that helped out a lot
like when i was going to college and
like picking out classes and picking out
the professors and yeah it's that's
awesome that they do that with their
with them with companies that's cool
yeah so you can check that out i'll put
a link to that article in the show notes
did you enjoy this stand-alone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free